so
first and foremost
first and foremost i'd like to offer our
condolences to the hutchins family
a speedy recovery to mr souza and our
concern for the safety
of all the men and women in the film
industry
on thursday october 21st 2001 at 1 48
p.m
we were dispatched to bonanza creek
ranch in reference to a 9-1-1 call
advising that two people had been shot
on a movie set
the first deputy arrived at two o'clock
p.m and ems arrived at 201 pm
it was later determined
that helena hutchins the director of
and joel
souza the director had been shot while
rehearsing a scene on the movie rust
during the initial investigation it was
determined that actor producer alec
baldwin was the person that fired the
weapon
we identified two other people that
handled and or inspected the loaded
firearm prior to baldwin firing the
weapon
these two individuals are armor
hannah reed gutierrez
and assistant director david halls
all three individuals have been
cooperative in the investigation
and have provided statements
over the last few days our investigative
team has been working diligently
to conduct interviews
execute search warrants
and collect and process evidence from
the scene
during this process we determined that
there were a limited amount of movie set
staff present in the area where the
actual incident took place
although there were approximately 100
people on set
through the execution of search warrants
we have collected about 600 items of
evidence
these include but are not limited to
three firearms
approximately 500 rounds of ammunition
and several pieces of clothing and
accessories
we believe that we have in our
possession the firearm that was fired by
mr baldwin
this is the buyer this is the firearm we
believe discharged the bullet
we also believe that we have the spent
shell casing from the bullet that was
fired from the gun
the actual lead projectile that was
fired has been recovered from the
shoulder of mr souza
the projectile was recovered by medical
personnel where he was being treated and
turned over to the sheriff's office as
evidence
we regard this specific spent casing
and recovered projectile to be the live
round that was fired from the revolver
by mr baldwin
we have recovered what we believe to be
possible additional live rounds on set
all the previous mentioned items along
with other items of evidence
will be submitted to the fbi crime lab
in quantico virginia for analysis
we are working thoroughly to gather all
the facts of the investigation
continue interviews and further further
analyze the pro and process the evidence
i want to ensure the victims their
families and the public
that we are conducting a thorough and
objective investigation
in reference to possible charges
it's too early right now in the
investigation to comment on charges at
this point
the investigation will continue and if
the sheriff's office determines during
our investigation a crime has occurred
and probable cause exists
arrest
an arrest or arrest will be made and
charges will be filed
otherwise we will complete our
investigation and forward the full
investigation and evidence to the
district attorney for review
before turning it over to the district
attorney i'd like to thank our investor
investigations division for all their
hard work and diligence in this case the
santa fe county public safety department
ems and recc
and the local fbi office for their
support and assistance in this case
also
uh the district attorney's office staff
that has been working side by side with
us during this case
i'd like to introduce first judicial
district attorney
mary carmich always
good morning
my name is mary carmack altwies and i am
the first judicial district attorney
thank you um which includes my
jurisdiction includes santa fe county
i echo the sentiments of sheriff mendoza
and want to send my condolences to the
family friends and tight-knit film
community impacted by this tragedy
we mourn the loss of helena hutchins and
the injury to joel souza
i also specifically want to thank the
santa fe county sheriff's department for
so thoroughly and actively investigating
this incident
our office appreciates your hard work
and together we will ensure that this
investigation is held to the highest
standards
i speak to the prosecutorial perspective
here
and i must emphasize that a complete and
thorough investigation is critical to d
a review
we take the corroborated facts and
evidence and connect it to new mexico
law
and we are not at that juncture yet
if the facts and evidence and law
support charges then i will initiate
prosecution at that time
i am a prosecutor that was elected in
part because i do not make rash
decisions and i do not rush to judgment
i rely on facts supported by evidence
cooperative and credible witnesses
and i cannot stress the importance of
allowing the santa fe county sheriff's
office to continue with their quality
investigation that is both serious and
complex
so at this point we will open it up to
questions
can we ask you so we've said that
based on the witness
that you've done can you tell us what
you've learned about how life of
ammunition was on the set uh and how it
made its way into that firearm you
learned that really target practice
maybe earlier that day what have you
learned on that right so i think what
we've learned is is we suspect that
there was other live rounds that were
found on the set i won't comment further
on how they got there that's still part
of a uh this investigation is active so
i won't comment on how they got there
but we know we suspect that they are
there that will be up it will be
determined when when the testing is done
by the crime lab in reference to whether
or not they are officially live rounds
or not
[Music]
that's that's uh what we're trying to
determine um the the
people that inspected or handled the the
firearm when it was loaded uh before i
got to mr baldwin we're interviewing and
there's some follow-up questions that we
need to do so there's uh further
investigation further interviews and uh
and we'll get we're gonna try and
determine exactly how that happened and
uh if they should have known that there
was a live round in that firearm
no i i said there was a total of 500
rounds of ammunition that is a mix of
blanks
dummy rounds and what we are suspecting
live rounds
found in the director's shoulder that
was recovered
well we know it was a lead projectile
it's still due to be determined by the
ballistic analysis by the fbi crime lab
exactly uh what the weight of that
bullet is uh maybe uh whether or not it
was fired from that actual firearm
there'll be uh the riflings and things
will be uh tested and uh and compared so
there's a lot of testing that that needs
to be done to ensure that that
projectile left that firearm and so
that's what we
a suspect on the movie does alex baldwin
himself face the potential of criminal
charges and if the da could perhaps
follow up with that as well that may be
a
question better answer by the district
attorney
all options are on the table at this
point i'm not taking i'm not commenting
on charges whether they will be filed or
not or on whom so
the answer is we we cannot answer that
question yet until we complete a more
thorough investigation
of interest right now
that's you
he's he's obviously the person that
fired the weapon so we're going to
continue interviewing and getting to
getting the facts of his statements and
the evidence and the case and possible
witnesses or anybody that has any
information so right now he is an active
part of this investigation
we hope so
as of right now um
everybody is cooperating with statements
and interviews
what the next step is you mentioned this
is an ongoing investigation but
specifically for your department what
does that mean specifically what do you
what else do you have to do so basically
there are a lot of interviews that have
to be done okay we've determined that
there were a limited amount of people or
movie staff that were actually um in the
vicinity of the incident so there's
there's also was approximately 90 people
on the movie set itself so there's a lot
of interviews that need to be done uh
still in this in this case and that's
going to be important
there's a lot of facts that are that are
floating around i wouldn't say facts may
be facts and rumors that are floating
around and it's our job to uh to figure
out if they're if they are facts or
rumors
fire not a blank not a dummy it was like
what people think of when you say
so
we would consider it a live round um a
bullet live because it did fire from the
weapon and obviously caused the death of
mrs hutching and and injured mr
souza
how much will you take into account
of unset unsafe practices and negligence
on other sets we know you will for this
set but there are reports coming out for
hannah and david of negligence
practices on other sets how much will
you take that
well
that's up to the district attorney to
determine how much that's going to weigh
but we are going to follow up on some of
those statements that are made
that there were other incidents we
definitely want to speak to anybody that
has any information in reference to
safety issues on further sets or whether
there were other issues and we would
encourage them to call the sheriff's
office at
505-986-2490 with any information they
may have
so we can get a good idea what the
totality of the circumstances are on
this set and what's happening in the
industry
[Music]
and that is something that will play
into our legal analysis when we get the
completed investigation from the
sheriff's department it obviously could
play into whether charges get filed or
not
you speak broadly about negligence and
the thing i know you said it's too early
to comment on charges but can you speak
broadly to what your office is examining
when it comes to an accidental shooting
versus weighing negligence like what
your office specifically looks at when
we get to that point
when we get to that point yes i will
speak to it i don't know that we are at
at that point yet
um because again we can't say that it
was negligent by negligence by whom how
many people were involved we can't say
that with any certainty at this point so
when we get to that point yes i will
speak to that
[Music]
okay
um i will i will talk in reference to
the caliber of the actual weapon that
was fired by mr baldwin that uh that
firearm was
on the f lee pierre
long colt 45 revolver were there other
rounds of ammunition
there there were other there was other
ammunition in the gun that we believe
was fired by mr baldwin
[Music]
i think that's an important point any
other live bullets in any of the other
guns including the one that you
recovered
as of right now there were three
firearms that were located on uh the set
within close proximity to the uh to the
incident
um
we're still going to determine we'll
send the firearm that was fired by mr
baldwin to the crime lab and do a
functionality test obviously it did fire
a live round
the other weapon is a a single action
army 45 revolver that one looks like
there's some modification to the
cylinder it may not be functioning but
that won't that will be determined by
the crime lab the other firearm is a
plastic non-functioning revolver
[Music]
before the accident and
people drinking or crew members drinking
the night before relaxed conditions can
you talk about that and specifically
i won't stop i won't talk about
specifics but we are aware of those um
of those rumors or those statements that
have been made and we're we'll we'll do
we're going to do the best to track
those down
there was a search warrant that was
issued in reference to any camera
footage um there was camera footage but
i can say that there was no footage of
the actual incident
alex baldwin's role as a producer factor
into
the investigation how much
responsibility do you think he actually
had as a producer and how could this
influence the
i think once we gather all the
statements of fact once we do all the
interviews then that will be weighed by
the district attorney to see exactly uh
you know what uh you know what weight
that's going to give and reference your
decision to making charges
um
just generally he has been cooperative
in this investigation
i won't comment on on my perception of
his demeanor
i won't comment on that
[Music]
i'll say right now until un until it's
proven by the crime lab it's a suspected
live round that was fired but it did
fire from the weapon and it dis did
caught it cause injuries so um that
would lead us to believe that it was a
live
round safety here on movies
you're obviously responsible for safety
in this county just curious about your
thoughts about the use of real weapons
on the sets of movies
well obviously uh i think the industry
has has had a record recently of being
safe i think there was some complacency
on this set and i think there are some
safety issues that need to be addressed
by the industry and possibly by the
state of new mexico but i'll leave that
up to uh to the industry and the state
to determine what those need to be
over here so have you ever covered a
case or is there a president for a case
like this in santa fe county where you
have somebody who fired a gun did it
clearly accidentally thought it was a
cold gun but other people loaded that
gun where it's kind of not the person
who actually fired it but could be held
liable is there any kind of precedent
for a case like this in your county
no
no there's no precedent whatsoever to
your investigation i mean this is a very
it's a tricky legal battle
uh it is a very complex case um it will
require lots of legal uh research and
analysis and review that's what my team
is here for and that's that's how we're
assisting the sheriffs at this point um
that said again we don't know how that's
going to play in until we get that that
complete investigation
was the projectile taken from the
director's shoulder removed from the
director's shoulder is that the same
projectile that killed calendar
we will leave that up to the office of
medical investigator to determine but uh
it's it's apparently the same round
going back to the questions about
whether there was target practice like
that are you investigating whether
people were recreationally shooting on
the ranch property aside from filming we
are aware of those statements and we are
investigating um whether or not that is
true or it isn't true and i would
encourage anybody that has any
information that any target practicing
or any firearm was discharged um away
from the movie set or or for practice or
or
for for whatever reason to to contact
the sheriff's office
i'm sorry you said two of the three guns
appear to be non-functioning on that
table
well i think the facts are clear uh a
weapon was handed to uh mr baldwin the
weapon is functional and fired a live
round
killing miss hutchins and injuring mr
souza you know the latest church
magistrate's foreign notes that hannah
gutierrez reed and joelle and um the av
that handed the gun all said live rounds
should never be on set yet there clearly
were live browns on set so
this feels almost like a false statement
to police how if if the armor is going
to say that there should never be a live
round on set yet there was what's your
next step as the law enforcement
investigator
we know there was one live round as far
as we're concerned on set we're gonna
determine whether we suspect that there
were other live rounds but that's up to
the testing but right now we're gonna
determine how those got there why they
were there because they shouldn't have
been there
[Music]
i'm sorry who were you asking about
he's been cooperative i'm not exactly
sure of his is it president's
whereabouts
they won't talk about the specifics of
that that's still um
being
i'll stay away from an actual timeline i
know you know based like on what i said
there's
several individuals that need to be
interviewed and from those interviews
comes new information that we need to
track down so i don't want to put a
timeline on it i want i want everybody
to know that we're working diligently
our investigative team is
to wrap this up
thoroughly and uh and completely and so
there is no timeline we want to get all
the facts get all the statements and
present that to the district attorney's
office for review
as questions come up
other information comes to light
there may be follow-up interviews
and and so i would uh suspect that we
would want to re-interview them
there was a small number of people
inside the area where this happened how
could it take you so long almost a week
now to get all of those done
well there was a small number of people
within the set area where the incident
took place those people have been
interviewed i'm talking about a hundred
people um in in the unseen in different
areas so those people that were
in close proximity to the incident
they've been uh interviewed and just for
clarity inside the revolver that alex
were there
not that we're aware
we're in that chamber
the sheriff used the word complacency on
set what is the bridge and how how much
do you have to go beyond complacency to
get to criminal negligence
hypothetically speaking
i'm not going to answer hypotheticals
today i will say there there is a bridge
and it will take uh
many more facts corroborated facts
before we can get to that criminal
negligence standard and again they're
they're gathering that as we
does not speak to criminal behavior
i can't say that without without
specifically legally researching that
but my off-the-cuff answer is no and for
the cherish for the sheriff your
experience with firearms
what is your view of such complacency on
the set of a movie
anytime firearms are involved there's
the safety is is paramount i'll say that
anybody knows that if you know anything
about firearms anytime a firearm is
around or about uh safety is paramount
um i i don't let my emotions get
involved this is an investigation we
rely on the facts thank you for actually
in that room you said a small number of
people
what is the small number
the information that i received from the
detectives there were 16 people in in
the vicinity of where the incident took
place
thank you for all your questions i
really appreciate it but i think that's
all the questions we're taking today
unless the d.a would like to entertain
anyone we're good
thank you thank you
[Applause]
one
[Music]
[Music]
you